so if you did not see this two days ago
uh Apple CEO Tim Cook unveiled Apple's
new 3 500 that's right thirty five
hundred dollars Vision Pro product this
is sort of VR augmented reality and more
we're going to show you about a minute
and a half of the launch because I think
this is also directly related to the
Meltdown of mainstream media how uh Tech
is overtaking Corporate press etc etc
take a look at this
I'm excited to announce an entirely new
AR platform with a revolutionary new
product and here it is
[Music]
introducing Apple Vision Pro
Vision Pro is a new kind of computer
that augments Reality by seamlessly
blending the real world with the digital
world
Vision Pro feels familiar yet it's
entirely new
you can see hear and interact with
digital content just like it's in your
physical space
and you control Vision Pro using the
most natural and intuitive tools your
eyes hands and voice
with Vision Pro you're no longer limited
by a display use your apps anywhere and
make them any size you want
capture photos and videos and relive
your most important memories in an
entirely new way
guys did you see Ready Player One some
of you maybe read the book Ready Player
one or did you see the movie The
Spielberg movie from a couple years ago
I mean it is happening right now I'm not
telling you that thing is inherently
evil I'm not telling you Tim Cook or
apple are inherently evil I'm not
telling you that I'll never try that
freaking thing I don't think I'm gonna
buy it but I'm not telling you I'm never
gonna put on the glasses and be like wow
this is kind of cool for a moment and
everything else but we we now have a
brief moment where you can feel them why
is it that Facebook changed the parent
company's name to meta and then started
trying to push everybody into the
metaverse right once they get you in
this thing that you wear in front of
your uh eyes and then you have augmented
reality that's what they call it a a AR
so augmented reality meaning you're
seeing a screen and you're seeing
reality together and it's like okay fine
you can play video games on it you can
do these things with your kids or you
can do all this stuff and again I'm not
saying it's all just evil in and of
itself but we have to know that that's
the direction that that a certain part
of humanity is going not everyone's
going to go in that direction but but a
huge amount of people are and there's
going to be a massive push to put us in
that world it's also like bizarrely
creepy and like why wouldn't you live in
reality how about that
Pro is Apple's first ever 3D camera
now you can capture photos and videos
with remarkable depth and relive a
memory
as if you're right back in the exact
moment
you could do that of course you could
also sit with your kids and not have to
film everything
[Music]
thank you